salut la team pantalon comme prévu pour
les trente mille abonnés nous faisons
une foire aux questions où vous posez
des questions et je donne la réponse
j'avais prévu de le faire pour les
trente mille abonnés juste le temps
qu'on mettait en place on est déjà passé
à exactement 32 1292 c'est grâce à vous
évidemment merci à vous d'être là depuis
le départ ou depuis récemment mais merci
d'être ici sur la chaîne c'est parce que
vous partagez les vidéos c'est parce que
vous en parler autour de vous que la
chaîne grossit de jour en jour et qu'on
peut faire des trucs de plus en plus
cool je vous donne donc 30 2292 poussant
les que fais-tu quand tu n'as pas du
tout dit d'esat est déjà arrivé long non
ça m'est pas encore arrivé
principalement parce que dès que j'ai
une idée je la note sur le cahier pour
pas l'oublier et en général je m'inspire
énormément de vos commentaires et de vos
discussions dans les commentaires
l'année prochaine posture faire une
vidéo par jour pendant un an
non non non nous non pour deux raisons
la première c'est que ce serait un petit
peu idiot de faire ça ce serait
redondant aujourd'hui ce qui est beau
c'est que c'est un défi de faire une
vidéo par jour pendant un an du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre
je trouve le concept intéressant si je
refais sa prochaine ça perdre son sens
par contre l'année prochaine je
n'arrêterai pas de faire des vidéos je
suis déjà en train de réfléchir ce qui
va se passer les prochaines le rythme
est aussi le contenu la manière de faire
les vidéos et la manière de me donner un
nouveau défi comment ressens-tu le
rapport que tu nous petit à petit avec
théa beauté peux-tu ressentir cela oui
je le ressens c'est celle où comme
question non j'ai tout à fait compris la
question je m'attendais pas du tout à ce
que vous soyez aussi engagé sur youtube
est ce qu'il ya une telle proximité un
tel lien et que vous apportiez autant en
fait aux créateurs c'est ce qui fait que
là j'ai l'impression d'avoir 32000 potes
en fait avec moi et j'ai vraiment envie
de faire les vidéos du coup puisque je
sais que vous êtes là derrière et que
vous êtes actif derrière quel est le
type de vidéo que tu préfères faire
chaque semaine
au tout départ la chaîne c'était une
vidéo faisait un tour à quelqu'un chaque
jour de la semaine
et puis au fur et à mesure j'ai étoffé
la chaîne en vous demandant votre avis
on n'était même pas 1000 à l'époque
quand ça a commencé à bouger et
aujourd'hui ce qui fait que je ne
m'ennuie jamais que je me lasse pas de
faire les vidéos c'est parce qu'il ya
plein de concept différent s'il y en
avait qu'un celle là je me lasserai tu
as déjà expliqué pourquoi tu faisais une
vidéo par jour mais comment t'es venue
l'idée de le faire eux écoutent l'idée
non elle est venue comme ça c'était au
mois de décembre donc le 1er janvier
arriver donc ça allait un peu de soi de
se dire un jeu comme fers un défi
pendant un an que je commence au 1er
janvier
l'idée est venue du coup assez
spontanément a tué déjà besoin de
retourner plus de deux fois une vidéo
pourtant tout raté alors non pas parce
que j'ai raté un tour mais ça m'est déjà
arrivé de refaire une vidéo comme celle
que vous êtes en train de voir en ce
moment parce que j'ai oublié de mettre
la caméra sur enregistrer voilà c'est ça
m'est déjà arrivé quatre fois depuis le
début de l'année c'est très très très
très frustrant de tours offerts pour
tout vous dire je reprends pas forcément
les mêmes questions qu'au premier coup
parce que ça perdrait en spontanéité par
contre si un jour je foire quelque chose
je vous le mets c'est promis parce que
je trouverais ça drôle au contraire est
ce que tu feras des vidéos tu mentale
''sera des personnes au hasard dans la
rue
j'adorerais faire ça j'aimerais beaucoup
faire ça néanmoins ça demande une petite
équipe
alors est-ce que je vais réussir à le
faire cette année je sais pas est ce que
je le ferai l'année prochaine c'est
probable une fois temps en temps parce
que là il faudrait dédier une journée
tournage à ça et pour moi aujourd'hui
une simple je me comprend 1 une simple
vidéo comme celle ci ça va prendre
quatre à cinq heures de la journée
pourquoi dans la description de tâche n
yat-il squeeze dans la chaîne similaires
parce que j'ai une chaîne de gaming qui
s'appelle mentale gaming on n'est pas
encore beaucoup d'abonnés je teste des
jeux rétro sur game boy salue ces
familles aujourd'hui on va tester le
nouveau tetris sur game boy advance
évidemment j'ai pas de chaîne gaming
mais c'est bien sur les algorithmes de
youtube qui te met les chaînes
similaires selon eux je pense que
squeeze et peut-être dans toutes les
chaînes similaire de toute l'échelle du
monde
bonjour battu faire ton spectacle à
dunkerque ou à lille alors je vous ai
dit qu'au mois de septembre j'annoncerai
toutes les dates de tournée qui vont
être de janvier à juin pour le rodage
les nouveaux spectacles
je te le dis en semi exclu
lille fait partie des premières dates tu
pourrais sortir un livre sur le
mentalisme ça fait plusieurs fois
qu'elle revient cette question écoute je
vais vraiment te dire j'ai adoré écrire
un livre sur le mentaliste parce que je
me dis avec tout ce que j'ai fait comme
contenu cette année sur la chaîne ce
serait juste une mise au papier et
pousser un petit peu plus le délire vous
j'aimerais beaucoup faire ça se voit un
projet que je déciderai tout seul dans
le sens où il faudrait une proposition
d'un éditeur situé éditeurs si vous
connaissez un éditeur
j'aimerais beaucoup mettre ses livres en
place as-tu inventé tous les tours que
lui présente le dimanche sinon d'où
vient-il
excellente question qui va me permettre
de m'exprimer sur le sujet effectivement
je crée les tours que je vous apprends
le dimanche pourquoi je vous donner la
raison je trouve pas ça vraiment cool
les gens qui expliquent ce qu'ils n'ont
pas créé eux-mêmes ou qui ne fait pas
partie du patrimoine classique on va
être le processus de création
c'est un vrai travail en fait où il ya
un espèce d'accouchement comme ça
d'idées il a toute une démarche
intellectuelle qui est hyper complexe
expliquait quelque chose qu'on a
créées soit mais ça revient à voler
l'idée de quelqu'un pour la donner comme
ça en pâture si les gens qui font ça un
jour créer quelque chose eux mêmes et
que quelqu'un m'explique à leur place
sans les citer ils vont ressentir
quelque chose de très violents en termes
d'émotion donc jamais jeunes
affligeraient ce à dire que même si la
loi protège bizarrement toutes ses
créations à deux tours là deux
anthologies elle impose par contre
évidemment je n'invente pas toutes les
techniques que j'utilise pour créer les
tours même si ça m'est arrivé d'inventer
des techniques pour les tours du
dimanche ou alors j'utilise des
techniques que je crois avoir créé mais
qu'on est déjà été créé avant mais
j'étais pas au courant ça aussi ça peut
arriver encore je fais une recette le
tour avec des ingrédients qui par contre
sont déjà existants les techniques quels
sont tes projets pour cette seconde
moitié d'année fille que j'aime beaucoup
la défis j'aime bien le fait le je vais
te le garder sa magnifique je te réponds
pas encore j'en parlerai jeudi prochain
dans leur sujet pourquoi nous souvenons
nous de certaines périodes précises de
notre vie avec une odeur une musique par
exemple
c'est ce qu'on appelle un ancrage je
t'invite à lire des choses sur la pnl ou
alors peut-être que tu veux me donner
une idée de vidéos je ferai une vidéo
sur les ancrages de même ça qui va se
passer
que penser d'une vidéo interactifs que
tu nous fais des tours on clique sur la
vidéo de nos choix
je trouve ça mortels je vais mettre un
petit coeur sur ton tweet comme ça je le
retrouverai je ne traite tout à l'heure
d'un caïd avait tiré vrai tu de faire
une vidéo à ou qui rêverait tune
mentaliser il ya quelques personnes à
qui je rêve de faire des vidéos ou de
mentaliser en vidéo ou de créer d'autres
concepts avec ces personnes là c'est les
frères bogdanoff yorick riche cas
alexandre astier et dans les youtube
heure là c'est cool parce que j'ai la
chance que y ait des choix des choses
qui se prépare donc je vais pas vous
donner les noms sur les choses qui sont
en cours de préparation mais parmi les
personnes que j'aimerais rencontrer avec
qui j'aimerais faire une vidéo
il ya poisson fait qu'on ya doc seven
bruce évidemment de la chaîne y penser
michael launay que j'ai découvert très
récemment sur youtube il ya vraiment pas
mal de gens que j'aimerais rencontrer
comme ça plein plein de youtube heures
et de youtube buzz comme ça que
j'aimerais vraiment rencontré est-ce que
ça t'arrive d'utiliser ton talent pour
certains jeux de société comme le
mastermind abbaoui évident mais vous
aussi je veux dire quand tu joues au
mastermind tu es obligé de réfléchir et
d'élaborer une stratégie de
compréhension donc oui en fait
aujourd'hui tu as plus de 30 mille
abonnés tue on espère combien
du défi et coûte quand j'ai lancé le
défi mon idéal c'était d'avoir douze
mille abonnés à la fin de l'année je
m'étais dit comme ça ça fait mille
abonnés par mois c'est très bien mais
les abonnés n'était pas un but en soi je
me dis ce qui serait vraiment mortel
c'est qu'à la fin de l'année y ait 100
mille espère que en un an du 1er janvier
au 31 décembre
cent mille abonnés sa boucle aurait bien
la boucle du défi mathématiquement
parlant c'est joli après ça me semble
très compliqué on a déjà passé la moitié
de l'année on a trente mille abonnés
c'est déjà plus de deux fois ce que
j'espérais sur l'année complète
donc je vais pas me plaindre du touch
même très heureux de ça et d'ailleurs
pour les cinquante mille abonnés
rappelez-vous j'ai annoncé quelque chose
de la vidéo numéro 100 si vous l'avez
pas vu regardez là mais il se passe
quelque chose pour les cinquante mille
signes astrologiques scorpions quand tu
nous fais une petite vidéo pour nous
apprendre à faire les rubik's cube
oui à partir de la semaine prochaine
voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette faq
vous m'avez posé beaucoup de questions
j'ai essayé de synthétiser de parler de
celle qui revenait le plus souvent
regardez bien la vidéo de jeudi prochain
c'est très important parce que je vous
annonce des choses pour cet été pour la
suite de l'année ce spies et comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure dans la
vidéo pour les cinquante mille abonnés
j'ai prévu un espèce de mental peuple on
s'en reparle si vous voulez plus de
détails vous regardez la vidéo numéro
100 sur 366 comme 366 jours de l'année
on n'en est pas là encore mais peut-être
que ça vous donnera envie de ramener
encore plus de monde sur l'achat tous
les créateurs sur youtube quand ils font
une faq pour les 30000 pour les 100 me
paraît désormais pour merci merci merci
mais c'est tellement vrai en fait au
départ je vous hais ils font encore les
remerciements des gens mais en fait on
en aurait envie de faire une vidéo on
dit une fois merci par nombre d'abonnés
n'oubliez pas avant de partir si cette
vidéo vous a plus de laisser un petit
pouce en l'air vous pouvez évidemment
laissé aussi des petits commentaires
pourquoi pas parce que je les lis tous
tous vraiment je les ai tous depuis le
débat et si bizarrement en regardant
cette vidéo vous n'étiez pas abonnés à
la chaîne il est grand temps de le faire
abonnez vous et rendez vous demain à 17h
ciao